Вітаю Вас.
Поговоримо з вами про геометричні фігури,
зокрема про коло і круг.
Все, що ми з вами намалюємо –
це геометричні фігури. Але вивчати
геометричні фігури, що складаються з
хаотично розміщених точок не має сенсу.
Краще відокремити такі геометричні фігури,
які складаються з точок, що мають певну
характерну властивість.
Такі геометричні фігури називаються
геометричним місцем точок.
Прикладом такої фігури є коло.
Коло – це геометричне місце
точок, що рівновіддалені,
тобто знаходяться на однаковій
відстані від заданої точки.
Це лінія, на якій розміщені ці всі точки,
які знаходяться на
однаковій відстані від заданої.
Задана точка є центром
(ми її зазвичай позначаємо О).
Якщо ми на колі візьмемо якусь точку,
наприклад, точку А і з`єднаємо її з
центром О, то ми отримаємо відрізок ОА,
цей відрізок називається радіус кола.
Якщо ми з`єднаємо дві точки кола,
і цей відрізок буде проходити через
центр кола, ми отримаємо діаметр.
Отже, АВ – це діаметр.
АО – це радіус (R); АВ – це діаметр (d).
Діаметр позначається літерою (d).
І якщо ми побачимо, що ОА і OB – це
радіуси (R), то діаметр (d) дорівнює 2R.
Якщо ми з`єднаємо точку A з якоюсь
іншою точкою C на колі, то ми отримаємо
відрізок, який називається хорда. Якщо ми
з`єднаємо C і B, ми теж отримаємо хорду.
Отже, АС і СВ – це хорди.
Увага на екран
Коло обмежує певну фігуру
і ця фігура називається круг.
Круг – це коло і точки,
що знаходяться в середині.
Що ж таке круг?
Круг – це геометричне місце
точок, що знаходяться
на відстані від заданої точки
не більше ніж додатне число.
Точка O, задана точка, є
центром нашого круга. Якщо ми
візьмемо на колі точку A
і з`єднаємо з центром (точкою O)
– отримаємо радіус кола,
а це є радіус круга.
Отже, AO=R (радіус круга, радіус кола).
Якщо ми з`єднаємо точку A з точкою B,
і цей відрізок буде
проходити через центр кола,
отримаємо діаметр (d) кола, а значить
і діаметр (d) круга. AB=d (діаметр).
Якщо ми візьмемо якусь
точку C в середині круга,
якусь точку Д в середині круга і
подивимось на відрізки OC і OД, то:
OCменше ніж відрізок ОА,
ОД менше ніж відрізок OA.
Це означає, що точки C і Д належать
нашому кругу.
Якщо ми візьмемо точку F
поза кругом, якщо ми візьмемо току K
і з`єднаємо центр з
точкою F чи з точкою К,
бачимо, що OF більше за OA;
OK більше за OA - це означає,
що точки F і K не належать нашому кругу.
Якщо ми візьмемо уявну мотузку і
прикладемо до кола, потім розправимо її
і виміряємо за допомогою
лінійки – то ми отримає довжину кола.
Довжина кола позначається
літерою С в деяких підручниках, або L.
Це одна і та сама величина.
Довжина кола розраховується за формулою
С= 2ПіR. Нагадаю Вам, що знак Пі = 3,14.
Пі – це число яке дорівнює
відношенню довжини кола до діаметра.
Формула вказана на дошці.
Площа круга позначається буквою S,
і визначається за формулою
S = ПіR квадрат.
Кола мають внутрішній дотик і
зовнішній дотик.
Коли кола доторкаються внутрішньо,
то О1 – це у нас центр першого
кола; О2 – це у нас центр другого кола;
відрізок до точки А від О1
– це радіус першого кола;
відрізок до точки А від О2 -
це радіус другого кола.
І відстань між центрами кіл О1О2 = R-r.
Якщо у нас зовнішній дотик, то
О1 – це у нас центр першого кола;
О2 – центр другого кола.
Відрізок від точки дотику А
до О2 – це радіус меншого кола.
Відрізок від О1 до точки дотику
А – це радіус великого кола.
Тоді відстань між колами О1О2= R+r
Розглянемо задачі.
Кола, радіуси яких 6 см і 2 см,
мають внутрішній дотик.
Знайдіть відстань між центрами цих кіл.
Ми бачимо, що ця задача відповідає
малюнку на внутрішній дотик,
І знаємо, що відстань між центрами
цих кіл розраховується як радіус
великого кола мінус
радіус маленького кола.
Отже, за умовою, нам сказано,
що радіус великого кола (R) = 6 см,
а радіус маленького кола (r) = 2 см.
Нам треба знайти відстань між
центрами кіл. Для цього О1О2 = 6-2 = 4 см.
Наступна задача.
Два кола мають зовнішній дотик,
а відстань між їх центрами
14 см. Знайдіть радіуси цих кіл,
якщо радіус одного з них на 4 см
більший за радіус другого.
Для другої задачі – малюнок на зовнішній
дотик. Отже, ми маємо,
що відстань між центрами кіл
дорівнює 14 см. О1О2=14 см.
Нам відомо, що більший радіус (R)
більший за маленький радіус (r) на 4 см.
Отже, якщо ми візьмемо радіус (r)
маленького кола за х,
то радіус (R) великого кола х+4.
Таким чином складемо рівняння, бо
О1О2 = R+r:
14 = х + 4 + х
14 = 2х+4
14 – 4 = 2х,
і звідси 2х =10
х = 5
Отже, ми бачимо, що радіус
маленького кола (r) дорівнює 5,
тоді, оскільки радіус великого (R) х + 4,
то радіус (R) великого кола буде 9.
Маємо відповідь: 5 і 9.
Наступна задача.
Три кола, радіуси яких 3 см, 4 см і 5 см
попарно дотикаються зовні.
Дивимось на екран.
Знайдіть периметр трикутника,
вершинами якого є центри кіл.
Ілюстрацією до цієї задачі є такий
малюнок (на дошці).
Три кола попарно зовнішньо
дотикаються одне до одного.
Тепер точка О3, точка О2, точка О1
– це центри відповідно наших кіл.
Далі з`єднаємо відстань О1О2, О3О1, О3О2.
Ми знаємо, що маленьке
коло має радіус 3 см,
отже відрізок до точки
дотику АО1 буде 3 см,
відрізок до точки дотику В теж 3 см.
(всі відрізки вказано на дошці).
Друге коло має радіус 4 см.
Отже О2В буде 4 і О2 до точки С
(точки дотику з третім колом) теж буде 4.
І відповідно, оскільки велике коло має
радіус 5 см, то О3А і О3С будуть по 5 см.
Таким чином ми можемо записати – чому
дорівнюють сторони нашого трикутника
О1О2О3.
О1О2 = 3 + 4 = 7 см; О2О3 = 4 + 5 = 9 см;
О3О1 = 5 + 3 = 8 см.
Оскільки нам треба знайти
периметр трикутника О1О2О3,
а ми знаємо, що периметр
– це сума всіх сторін.
Отже, периметр трикутника цього
трикутника буде сума всіх сторін:
О1О2О3 = 7 + 9 + 8 = 24 см
Наступна задача.
(Увага на екран)
На рисунку точка О – центр кола,
кут СОД дорівнює куту МОК.
Довести, що СД = МК.
Малюнок до задачі під номером 1.
Отже ми маємо коло з центром у точці О.
У нас сказано, що кут
СОД дорівнює куту МОК.
Нам треба довести, що СД
(це наша хорда) дорівнює МК.
Коли ми уважно подивимось на
малюнок, то побачимо два трикутники.
Перший трикутник СОД і трикутник МОК.
Отже, розглянемо трикутники СОД і МОК.
За умовою кут СОД = куту МОК.
Далі СО – це радіус нашого
кола, МО – радіус нашого кола.
СО = МО = R.
ОД і ОК теж радіуси нашого кола,
тобто ОД = ОК, як радіуси нашого кола.
Отже, ми маємо дві сторони і
кут між ними одного трикутника,
відповідно дорівнюють двом сторонам
і куту між ними другого трикутника
– за першою ознакою рівності
трикутників такі трикутники рівні.
Отже, ми можемо зробити
висновок, що ΔСОД = ΔМОК
(за першою ознакою рівності трикутників).
Якщо ΔСОД = ΔМОК, то
рівні їхні відповідні сторони.
Звідси ми маємо висновок, що СД = МК.
Доведено те, що нам потрібно було довести.
Наступна задача.
Дивимось на екран.
Відрізки АВ і АС – відповідно
діаметр і хорда кола.
Хорда АС дорівнює радіусу
кола. Знайдіть кут ВАС.
Для другої задачі рисунок на дошці.
Є коло з центром в точці О і ми маємо,
що відрізок АВ – це діаметр,
а відрізок АС – це хорда. Запишемо це.
Увага на екран
В умові нам сказано, що
хорда АС = радіусу кола.
Отже, ОА у нас радіус, ОВ – у
нас радіус і АС – радіус.
Увага на екран
Нам треба знайти значення кута ВАС.
Позначу його червоним,
оцей кут нам треба знайти.
Увага на екран
Давайте з`єднаємо точки О і С,
отримали трикутник АОС.
В цьому трикутнику АО – радіус,
ОС теж радіус,
АС – хорда, яка дорівнює радіусу.
Таким чином ми бачимо, що всі три
сторони трикутника рівні.
Отже ΔАОС – рівносторонній
(у рівностороннього
трикутника усі кути рівні).
Оскільки сума кутів трикутника
дорівнює 180 градусів,
то кут ОАС нашого
трикутника буде дорівнювати
180 градусів поділити на 3 = 60 градусів.
Можливо з вас хтось пам`ятає,
що у рівносторонньому
трикутнику всі кути по 60 градусів,
то можна зразу написати, що
кут ОАС = 60 градусів.
Оскільки кут ВАС це той же самий кут ОАС,
бо ВС є точка на продовженні відрізка ОА,
то ми можемо сказати, що кут ВАС дорівнює
60 градусів. Маємо таку відповідь.
Наступна задача.
Дивимось на екран.
У колі з центром в точці О
проведено діаметр DF і хорду FЕ.
Знайдіть кут FDЕ, якщо кут FЕО
дорівнює 23 градуса.
Отже, ми маємо коло з центром в точці О.
DF – діаметр, і проведена хорда FЕ.
Треба знайти кут FDЕ.
З’єднуємо. Оцей кут треба знайти.
Увага на екран
Якщо відомо, що кут FЕО
дорівнює 23 градуси. Запишемо.
Увага на екран
Подивимось на наш малюнок.
Ми бачимо, що ОЕ, ОF і ОD
– це радіуси нашого кола.
Зараз нас цікавлять саме відрізки FО і ОЕ,
бо вони входять в трикутник FОЕ
де відомий кут.
Отже, розглянемо трикутник FОЕ,
у якому FО = ОЕ = R (радіус).
Якщо дві сторони трикутника рівні,
то такий трикутник рівнобедрений.
Отже, трикутник FОЕ рівнобедрений.
Ми знаємо, що в рівнобедреного
трикутника кути при основі рівні.
Кут ОFЕ і ОЕF – це кути при основі.
Таким чином кут ОFЕ також 23 градуси.
Запишемо це.
Увага на екран
Далі, нам потрібно
знайти значення кута FDЕ.
Ми бачимо, що кут FDЕ, а це є і
кут ОDЕ, входить в трикутник ОDЕ.
Подивимося на цей трикутник.
Якщо ми знайдемо ці кути,
то зможемо знайти кут ОDЕ.
ОЕ і ОD – радіуси нашого кола.
Отже, трикутник ОDЕ:
OD = ОЕ – це радіус нашого кола.
Якщо у нас у трикутника дві сторони
рівні, то трикутник ЕОD є рівнобедреним.
Увага на екран
Якщо трикутник ОDЕ є рівнобедреним,
то кути при основі рівні.
Тобто кут ОDЕ і кут DЕО будуть рівними.
Далі, кут ЕOD – є зовнішнім
для трикутника FОЕ.
Увага на екран
Ми знаємо, що зовнішній кут дорівнює
сумі кутів трикутника не суміжних з ним.
Тобто, цей кут DОЕ буде
дорівнювати 46. Запишемо це.
Увага на екран
Кут FOE - зовнішнішній
Кут DОЕ = кут ОFЕ + кут ОЕF.
Кут DОЕ = 23 градуси + 23 градуси
=  46 градусів.
Якщо Ви забули про цей факт і не
побачили, що кут DОЕ є зовнішнім,
можна було знайти цей кут іншим шляхом.
Оскільки в трикутнику FОЕ відомі
вже два кути, а сума кутів 180 градусів,
ви могли б знайти цей кут FОЕ,
він би дорівнював 134 градуси.
Оскільки FОD є розгорнутим кутом,
то щоб знайти кут DОЕ треба було 180
градусів мінус 134 градусів = 46 градусів.
Оскільки трикутник DOЕ -
рівнобедрений, кути при основі рівні,
а кут при вершині 46 градусів, то
на ці два кути припадає 134 градуси.
Отже, кут (який нам потрібно знайти) ОDЕ =
134 градусів поділити на 2 = 67 градусів.
Оскільки кут FDЕ це то й же самий
кут ОDЕ, бо F лежить на продовженні,
то і кут FDЕ буде дорівнювати 67 градусів.
Наступна задача.
Дивимось на екран.
На рисунку хорда МЕ
перетинає діагональ СD в точці А.
Кут МNА дорівнює куту
ЕFА і дорівнює 90 градусів.
Кут МАN дорівнює 30 градусів. А сума
довжин відрізків МN і ЕF дорівнює 16 см.
Знайдіть хорду ЕМ. Малюнок, який
ілюструє цю задачу Ви бачите на дошці.
Є коло з центром в точці О. Є діаметр
СD, який перетинає хорда ЕМ в точці А.
Відомо, що кут МNА – 90 градусів.
Кут АЕF теж 90 градусів.
Кут МАN – 30 градусів.
І відомо, що NМ + ЕF дають 16 см. Нам
треба знайти дожину ЕМ. Запишемо це.
СD – діаметр, ЕМ – хорда, перетинаються
в точці А. Кут МNА = 90 градусів.
Кут АFE = 90 градусів.
Кут МАN = 30 градусів. NМ + ЕF = 16 см.
Нам треба знайти, чому дорівнює ЕМ.
Коли ми подивимось на малюнок, то
побачимо два трикутники МNА і ЕFА.
Ці трикутники прямокутні.
Увага на екран
Кут МАN – 30 градусів, але кут ЕАF
теж 30 градусів – бо ці кути вертикальні.
Запишемо це. Кут МАN і кут
ЕАF вертикальні, отже рівні.
Кут МАN = кут ЕАF=30 градусів.
А ми з вами знаємо, що катет,
який лежить проти кута в 30 градусів,
дорівнює половині гіпотенузи.
Дивимось, катет МN лежить
проти кута в 30 градусів.
В трикутнику МNА – МА якраз гіпотенуза.
Якщо ми МN візьмемо за х, то
МА за цією властивістю буде 2х.
В трикутнику ЕАF – ЕА
гіпотенуза, а ЕF – це той катет,
який лежить проти кута в 30 градусів.
Якщо ми ЕF візьмемо за у, то
ЕА в нас буде дорівнювати 2у.
Повертаємось до умови. Ми з вами ще
не використали умову: МN + ЕF = 16 см.
Оскільки МN ми взяли за х, а
ЕF – взяли за у, то ми маємо,
що х + у = 16
Тоді наша невідома МЕ (хорда)= ЕА + АМ;
МЕ = 2у + 2х. винесемо двійку
за дужки. Маємо: МЕ = 2(у + х),
оскільки х + у = 16, то ми можемо
записати: МЕ = 2 помножити на 16 = 32.
Отже, таким чином ми маємо
МЕ, наша хорда, дорівнює 32 см.
Сьогодні ми з вами повторили теоретичний
матеріал і порозв`язували задачі
на тему «Коло і круг».
На наступному уроці розглянемо дотичну,
яка проводиться до кола, і її властивість.
На сьогодні все. До побачення!